for yon bashanu the sounds of footsteps
in this corridor are still familiar
for 12 years he was imprisoned in a tiny
cell at the notorious fort thirteen of
sheila prison
his crime
knowing someone who opposed the romanian
regime
all of that is 50 years ago now
but barshanu remembers every day of it
they were animals
they humiliated us kicked us with their
boots beat us with clubs
for no reason
between 1957 and 1958 we were tortured
every day
the animals barshanu means are men like
this one former prison boss alexandru
vicinesku
now 88 years old bishinesku is the first
romanian prison worker to be tried for
crimes under the communist regime
he's being held personally responsible
for the death of several inmates in the
1950s and 60s
i'm innocent i was just a lonely
official
for the plaintiffs the fact that this
case has even come to trial so long
after the end of communism is in itself
a triumph
for 23 years there was no political will
to resolve this issue
the people who took over power in the
1990s stifled any kind of discussion
and this communist elite carried on in
politics even after the 90s
he's referring to people like rodi
casteno
once a member of the feared romanian
security apparatus the security tata
sunoyu was also romanian justice
minister from 2000 to 2004
she has always dismissed the idea of
punishing crimes committed under
communism
the statute of limitations has long
expired
now the public prosecutor is trying to
categorize these cases as genocide
but from a judicial point of view that
won't wash
they weren't murders committed on ethnic
or religious grants this was about
political affiliation
from a legal standpoint stu know you may
be right until recently there was a
statute of limitations in cases of
murder meaning the perpetrators could be
off the hook
former prison guard juan cartier is the
only one to speak publicly about his
crimes he's written a book and even
starred as himself in a film
the enemy had to be stamped out that's
what the party wanted he explains today
we invented our own laws in that prison
we were god
no one had a bad conscience torture was
the norm
the institute for the investigation of
communist crimes says it has identified
34 prison supervisors
after them it wants to bring prison
guards like yuan katicia to trial
he says he became addicted to inflicting
torture
i loved using my baton
it didn't matter whether i struck
someone once or a thousand times
i just didn't care
the inmates in this prison were also
beaten many times
alexandro viscinescu was prison
superintendent here at romney kusarat
back then valentin christia was kept in
isolation in cell number 13.
even today christia is struggling to
come to terms with those dark days
today the prison boss gets a pension of
around 850 euros and i'm getting 400.
that's the way it is i don't think
prosecution will achieve anything i
don't have any illusions
it's too late for justice say valentin
christia yon barcanu and many other
victims
but they still believe that any attempt
to shed light on the crimes of romania's
communist past is worth it